[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is really bad and welcome to
[Music]
okay you look scary don't be scared
fine go get will be awaiting me today
and answering I don't know doing fried
food by the sound might be a little echo
and stuff like that but Dad that's okay
that's not quebra she's scared it's gay
but anyway what surprise it read it by
another we don't trying to make out with
me don't make out for me so I don't know
if you notice brothers but there's been
some changes with my channel basically
I'm uploading three instead of two
videos I'm trying it's not gonna be that
every day but it's really pushing my
limits like four videos with editing and
rendering time I just think that's
impossible but maybe in the future who
knows I'm gay I think I feel like I feel
really good about it it gives I know
it's some of you bros would be really
nice and saying I go pretty you don't
have to make free video if you can you
do whatever you want but I know it gives
me more room to experiment hello and do
kind of different stuff as well so I'm
actually enjoying it a lot and doing
making more videos I'm also starting to
enjoy life in Italy a lot here the
weather is always really nice and I hear
it's really bad in Sweden right now I
still am in Sweden of course then I am
coming back to Sweden I know everyone is
like huh yeah ever coming back to Sweden
he's not leaving Sweden isn't his column
novel in this idea a lot I was going to
go that if you know last night I don't
know what accent that was well would I
get 100 my niece married you suck go
back even if pooyan and took her guy
with me on the plane she was really good
it was really good yeah okay it feels
really good
I'm enjoying it here
but we'll see we'll see sitting in the
basement now is where I record these
days I feel like I fit a little too
dramatic zooming unintentionally I feel
like there are a lot of stuff that I can
talk about in Friday's new computer fine
but a lot of them are like HQ miss you
know the whole you know drama between
commentator and what other people do and
stuff like that but I don't really want
to talk about stuff like that I really
wanted my channel to be more of a fun
thing I mean I think it's kind of
obvious that I don't like the fact that
people go to other channels and you know
say bad things to them because they're
playing the same games although there is
honestly sometimes it does actually
bother me I feel it's it's funny I don't
know I feel like if someone is copying
me like making the same thumbnails
putting my name in the tags doing that
kind of stuff and just in playing the
same games trying to leach of me I of
course I don't appreciate that but of
course if there are different games that
people play and there's a different
style on it then you know of course it's
obvious you know me I don't own the
games I play or whatever but you know
sometimes it does actually bother me a
little bit but it's not that often and I
really appreciated more if people are
when our people are more upfront about
it instead of just being a bit I didn't
copy potato pie it's like he played the
game by playing like two seconds ago I'm
not saying that's copying my just feel
like a little lame dude and say that you
didn't get it from me then I'm
you can be upfront about it III
appreciate it
all right to make a long story short
what I wanted to say here is don't go to
other channels and say bad things to
them
that I want Bruce to be Bros you know I
don't I want the bro army to be a
positive thing not not spreading hate
and stuff like that
so yeah thank you another news we reach
900 thousand subscribers we've been the
fastest growing channel and use it again
I don't get it I really really really
don't get it um I just look at the
statistic sometimes and I'm like oh
we're number one again oh of course
that makes so much sense because I
really don't know why but I I'm not
complaining and I'm really really happy
about it I mean bro army it's so strong
bro army would take over the world and
the first thing we'll ever do is kill
the battles extinguish all exterminate
all the barrels that's move that's step
number one
I feel like I should start doing stuff
in these maybe you brothers have
suggestions what I can do if you haven't
suggested from what you're doing Friday
could be bad but damn blue if you bros
been noticing that I start making face
isn't something like that in the video
that couldn't fun are dedicated just to
that it's really cool I don't know I
always like the Ching I'm so crazy I'm
so creative I have all these ideas
nobody I don't know it's just funny I
guess I don't know I don't know what I'm
talking about do i I don't think so but
I do know that I love you risk and I as
always I appreciate everything you bros
do all right being the professional I am
I ran out of battery disk space i play
my girlfriend because she wouldn't let
me borrow the other disk so anyway I
don't know where I'm supposed to look so
this probably feels really awkward but
thanks for all the support brothers I
can't tell you I'm shaking because I'm
tired okay I can't tell you both enough
how much it means to me that you staying
so supportive and
you know stay with me all feel like it's
a journey we do together so we'll end
this with a brofist
if you haven't brofist it before come on
man it's time to put your fist up get it
up there
don't hesitate last chance last time do
it do it now
don't hit I'm forcing you rich all right
so anyway thousand breath
[Music]